what was the deal with that uh
with that colby massive at all that
thing was so wild huh yeah i mean how'd
you imagine doing that
hit cold [ __ ] and something like this
the whole thing like the thing of in
your head like okay you know where the
guy is you're gonna roll up there you're
gonna put a mask on that's like some
thug gangster [ __ ] that you know i would
i
grew up in helena montana i'm not
raised to do that
he grew up in the [ __ ] streets doing
[ __ ] maybe not like that but fighting
and so that probably seemed
normal-ish to him yeah
just how he was raised
yeah it just seems so wild like imagine
as you're walking it was i guess it was
just him and bob metery i just listened
to uh bob mannery on um raw talk with
bradley martin that little dude oh yeah
and uh yeah he explained bob explained
kind of what happened but
yeah i must have just found out the
location they were obviously posting on
their stories and [ __ ] hit him a
couple times by bop and dipped damn it's
crazy but you know after that fight with
jorge and colby jorge is just [ __ ]
fuming he wanted to win it so bad for
his team for that [ __ ] city and
everything and after he just [ __ ]
want to do something well dude colby
posted like five days in a row 50 45 15
45
like five days in a row on instagram
tagging jorge just
toxic
talking [ __ ] but
i don't know it's
there's a fine line between
entertainment
and making it personal and some people
are on different lines colby's on the
entertainment line jorge was on the
personal line and i think colby was on
the personal line too but
i don't know it's just not a good look
for jorge people loved it when he did it
at the leon
boom
pieced him up right there loved it who
leon spanx leon edwards early on he had
a backstage at the ufc boom two three
piece and a biscuit people [ __ ] loved
that maybe jorge thought i'm gonna go do
it to colby people would love it maybe
he didn't that maybe that didn't cross
his mind i don't know i'm a fan of both
regardless of it yeah it's weird that
actually this the
i don't know and then what do you face
after that and he just had a big
contract it just seems like a lot to
kind of risk but yeah he must have been
just real real angered up or maybe a
little
yeah a couple bumps here yeah oh dude
you even in yeah
yeah you could get a bump off of
anything there i wonder how much it'll
cost them a quarter mil maybe
yeah who knows lawyer fees [ __ ]
paying colby out yeah who knows he said
he he hit he plead not guilty right yep
so who knows if he was even and then he
went on twit uh twitter and said you
shouldn't talk about my kids then nate
diaz said
you just called you just [ __ ] gave
yourself up or turned yourself in or
whatever he scuffed uh colby's rolex
ninety thousand
hmm yeah
but some company will fix that just to
say they fixed it you know somebody
would help with that probably well
colby's probably gonna get that from
jorge say hey you need 50 000 just for
the rolex yeah
no one's heard of heard from colby yet
either it adds oh that's interesting
like did something really happening
could have really i mean dude you get
hit like that you could give bad
concussions i'm sure his lawyers like
don't say [ __ ] yeah that could be it too
and then not hear from colby is kind of
rare too
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one